hi guys sci-fi recapped here today I am
going to explain the show called A
Series of Unfortunate Events spoilers
ahead watch out and stay safe the movie
revolves around the Three Bottle air
children Violet Klaus and sunny Violet
is the eldest child and she has a real
knack for inventing and building unusual
devices while Klaus is the middle child
and the only boy he likes wearing
glasses to make himself look more
intelligent than violet last but not
least is sunny who makes up for her lack
of communication skills with the size
and sharpness of her four teeth they
lived in an enormous mansion in the
heart of the city until their parents
perished in a fire that also destroyed
their massive home the authorities spent
months on research to find the precise
cause of the bottle air fire but without
success the bottle air children were
devastated but their parents left behind
an enormous fortune and a mysterious
object that Rings a very faint Bell
Violet will inherit the bottle air
estate when she comes of age until then
they will be placed under a proper
Guardian as decided by the executor of
the bottle era estate Mr Poe and bankers
at Mortuary money management after a lot
of deliberation Mr Poe and others choose
a man named Count Olaf as the guardian
of the bottle air children Count Olaf is
said to be the closest living relative
of the family but the children don't
ever recall meeting him Count Olaf is a
self-proclaimed actor and lives in a
dark and dilapidated Mansion it quickly
becomes clear that he is after the
children's massive inheritance class
doesn't like Olaf from the get-go
especially the tattoo on his ankle but
Violet convinces him to compromise Olaf
talks rudely to them and makes them
prepare dinner for his Shady theater
friends meanwhile it is revealed that Mr
and Mrs baudelaire are not dead after
all and they are in Peru Olaf forces
Violet to play the role of his wife in
his play and tricks her into marrying
her in front of Mr Poe and others
however Violet reveals that the marriage
is not legal because she didn't sign the
marriage certificate with her right hand
exposed and afraid of getting arrested
Olaf and his accomplices run away it is
revealed that Olaf wasn't the closest
living relative in fact fact he wasn't
related to the bottle air family at all
Mr Poe apologizes to the children for
the mix-up and sends them to Dr
Montgomery a longtime friend of Mr and
Mrs baudelaire enraged Olaf kills
Montgomery's assistant Gustav for
assisting Mr Poe in safely transporting
the children on a positive note Dr
Montgomery lives in a luxurious Villa
and he welcomes the children with a
freshly baked cake Dr Montgomery claims
to have grown up with Mr and Mrs
baudelaire but Violet and class don't
recall them ever talking about him to
prove himself Dr Montgomery shows them a
picture of a piano and claims that he
was locked inside it with Mr and Mrs
baudelaire he also tells the children he
is a herpetologist and gives them a tour
of his laboratory which he calls the
reptile room the room gives off the
false impression that it has been
secured with a top-of-the-line security
system but in reality it can be opened
by just turning the doorknob it contains
all kinds of reptiles including a new
species of non-poisonous snake called
the deadly Viper that Dr Montgomery
recently discovered and plans to present
to the herpetological society the room
also contains an entire cabinet full of
Venom samples from some of the most
venomous snakes known to men seeing the
children being afraid of the animals Dr
Montgomery tells them that a few
dangerous reptiles can make them
skeptical of the entire species but if
they give them a chance and get to know
them well enough to tell the Dangerous
Ones from the good no harm will come to
them from the reptile room he promises
to take them to the movies later before
heading to town to run some errands
Violet and Klaus go through his books
and find a blueprint of his Landscaping
which makes a labyrinth Violet notes
that from the top it looks like the
tattoo on count Olaf's ankle shortly
afterwards Count Olaf shows up at the
Villa in Disguise pretending to be Dr
Montgomery's new assistant Violet and
class take no time identifying him and
try to lock him out but he forces his
way into the house with a knife Olaf
also confirms Dr Montgomery's claims
about the picture on the wall revealing
that he took the picture himself he
eventually Corners the children but Dr
Montgomery's cuckoo clock startles him
giving the children time to lock
themselves in the reptile room soon Dr
Montgomery arrives but to the children's
dismay Olaf manages to trick him into
believing that he's there to take the
role of his new assistant after sending
Olaf to his room Dr Montgomery reveals
he's well aware that Olaf's an imposter
and convinces them to play along and
feign ignorance when alone class
suggests calling the authorities but
Montgomery turns down the idea as Olaf
and his henchmen could easily overpower
them before the cops can show up keeping
up the ruse Dr Montgomery invites Olaf
to the movie so they could keep an eye
on him and plan their next step cloth
gives his father's last remaining
possession to Dr Montgomery and it turns
out to be a monocular Dr Montgomery
watches the movie through the monocular
and discovers a secret message left
behind by Mr baudelaire in it the
message asks Dr Montgomery to take the
children to Peru on the SS Prospero
Olive catches up to Dr Montgomery's
deceit and orders his henchmen to take
him out to his surprise the the
herpetologist manages to beat them and
confronts Olaf outside the movie theater
however it turns out Dr Montgomery is
under the false impression that Olaf was
sent by his Rivals at the herpetological
society underestimating the threat Olaf
poses to him and the children Dr
Montgomery lets him go after confronting
him at the theater before putting the
kids to bed Dr Montgomery tells them
about their Voyage to Peru later he
notices the door of the reptile room
strangely open and Ventures into it the
next day Violet and class discover the
dead body of their beloved Uncle
Montgomery in the reptile room Violet
blames Olaf who arrives shortly
afterwards but he denies his involvement
pointing to the snake bite marks on
Monty's cheeks Olaf then forces Violet
and her siblings into his car at knife
point to drive them to catch the ship to
Peru however before they could leave Mr
post shows up the children tell Mr Poe
that Stefano is Olaf In Disguise but the
latter shows Mr Poe his tattooless ankle
to prove that he's not Olaf Olaf then
seizes the children's passport from Mr
Poe that he brought on the request of
the late Monty when Mr Poe insists on
waiting for the authorities to arrive
before letting Stefano and the children
go to Peru one of Olaf's henchmen shows
up posing as a nurse after performing a
sham autopsy the fake nurse declares
that Dr Monty died of snake bite
claiming to have found the Venom of the
deadly Viper in the deceased vein Violet
and class tell Mr poets impossible to
die from the bite of the deadly Viper
because it's a non-poisonous snake and
its name is a misnomer but they can't
prove it because the snake is missing
from its cage nevertheless to keep Mr
Poe from leaving with the children Olaf
declares a sham quarantine in the name
of containing the spread of the poison
of the deadly Viper Violet and class
again try to tell Mr Poe that Stefano is
Olaf but the banker refuses to believe
them without proof and sends them to
their room as Olaf's henchmen keep Mr
Poe distracted Olaf follows the children
to their room however when gets to the
room he finds it empty it is revealed
that Klaus has sneaked into the reptile
room while Violet has run outside to
Olaf's car with sunny class finds the
message left by his parents to Monty in
his notebook while Violet breaks into
Olaf's suitcase soon Olaf gets to Violet
but everyone's suddenly forced to rush
to the living room when the deadly Viper
surrounds baby Sunny Mr Poe and others
panic but class calmly reads Monty's
note saying the deadly Viper couldn't
even hurt a fly let alone a human Violet
then brings Olaf's suitcase which
contains an empty Mamba do Mal Venom
sample bottle that he stole from Monty's
Venom sample cabinet and a double barrel
syringe with which Olaf administered the
poison into Monty's body simulating the
double puncher Mark of a snake Mr Poe
finally believes the children and asks
to see Stefano's ankle again this time
Mr Poe wiped Stefano's ankle revealing
Olaf's Infamous tattoo that had been
covered by makeup in the face of the
damning evidence Olaf Reveals His
identity and he also comes clean about
killing both Monty and his assistant
Gustav Mr Poe orders the police to
arrest Olaf and he finally learns that
they are actually Olaf's San Olaf and
his thugs seemingly have the upper hand
until the late Monty's reptiles unite
and attack them afraid for their lives
Olaf and his goons run into the
Labyrinth however refusing to let them
get away Klaus and violet closely follow
them while Mr Poe calls the police the
children almost Corner Olaf but he
manages to escape using a secret exit
upset class finally shows Violet the
message their parents left for Monty and
laments not getting to ask their uncle
about it he also reveals that Olaf stole
the mono killer using which Monty
decoded Mr and Mrs baudelaire's message
next it is revealed that the statue in
the center of the labyrinth is actually
Mr Poe's assistant Jacqueline she
apologizes for failing to help Monty and
Promises the children to bring Olaf to
Justice seeing a similar monocular his
money in her possession the children
figure out that she knows what's going
on around them and bombard her with
questions about Peru Jacqueline says
Peru has been compromised and tells them
to find their Fierce and formidable Aunt
Josephine instead saying she can keep
them safe and tell them everything they
need to know Jacqueline then goes after
Olaf while the children return back to
Mr Poe and ask him to take them to their
Aunt Josephine Mr Poe agrees and on
their way to Josephine's place the
children ask Mr Poe about their
secretary and the banker reveals that he
hired her on the recommendation of Mr
and Mrs baudelaire following the trail
of evidence left behind by Olaf
Jacqueline tracks him in the SS Prospero
she tries to apprehend him but he
manages to escape however Jacqueline
manages to retrieve Monty's monocular in
the final scene Mr and Mrs bottlair try
to contact Monty all the way from Peru
unaware that he is no more thanks for
watching subscribe and hit that like
button to help our Channel grow turn on
the notifications so you won't miss any
of our new videos